hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast vs. screening program a ducati
community healthcare system I am Judy /
arka blabbered and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
webcast is presented by labret skaam the
leading social media site for science
professionals and sponsored by roche
diagnostics as a global leader in health
care roche diagnostics offers a broad
portfolio of tools and help healthcare
professor providers in the early
detection prevention diagnosis and
treatment of diseases in molecular
diagnostics the company is driven by a
vision of working with laboratories like
yours to improve the medical value you
offer in microbiology infectious
diseases oncology and genomics roche
diagnostics continues to meet unmet
needs through its investment in research
innovation and scientific excellence
with the goal of supporting your
important role in improving patients
lives before we start there are a few
instructions we want to hear from you
during this interactive broadcast so
please ask questions or leave us a
comment the answers are welcome to you
can do this by hitting the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window and typing in your
comments and questions we'll try to get
to as many as we can and we'll follow up
if we don't have time today on a better
look you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you can't hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button on the top right or use
the Q&A button we'll make sure we try to
resolve any issues now let's get right
to today's presenter we are proud to
welcome dr. Rodney Arcenas clinical
scientist in microbiology immunology and
molecular at pathology consultants of
south broward LLP within memorial
healthcare system dr. arsonist earned a
BS with honors in microbiology from the
University of Florida in spring of
nineteen ninety-seven
he continued his microbiology training
at the University of South Florida
College of Medicine graduating in 2002
with an ms and PhD in medical
microbiology and immunology dr. Arcenas
was then accepted into the clinical
microbiology fellowship program at the
Mayo Clinic in Rochester Minnesota after
completing his fellowship he was hired
in 2004 at lab one incorporated in
lenexa kansas to be the scientific
director of microbiology and immunology
he left lab 1 in 2006 to join the
pathology consultants of south broward
pcs V as their clinical scientist for
microbiology and molecular testing and
has been there since in his time with
pcs be dr. Arcenas has helped to start
the molecular infectious disease testing
service which has grown from a day shift
operation with two medical technologists
eight hours Monday through Friday to
having five full-time and three
part-time medical technologists with
24-hour shifts monday through friday and
and irradiated one and a half shifts on
weekends he has also helped spearhead
the implementation of a successful mersa
active surveillance program that started
in 2008 dr. Arcenas is board certified
as a diplomate of the american board of
medical microbiology i will now turn it
over to dr. Arcenas for his presentation
well thank you for the introduction and
thank you everyone for joining us today
so as mentioned i will be discussing vs
screening program and in particular our
environment in our setting and kind of
go over the drivers and implementation
and planning and development and some of
the outcome metrics related to our
development and implementation of
immersive screening program so very
briefly some of the objectives will be
discussing today's again understanding
what kind of drove us and to developing
an active surveillance program also
discuss kind of the planning
implementation within a multi hospital
community healthcare system and then
lastly to show some of the downstream
successes of our mercy screening program
so just a very brief background about
our environment down here we're located
in broward county which you can see here
in south florida the county colored in
red and we're actually in the lower half
of that county and we're a total of six
hospitals one of which is a children's
hospital in total we have about 2,100
for beds and it's a third largest public
health care system in the United States
that sort of drilling down into that
South Broward County what we have here
going from left to right or west to east
we have our hospitals near amar ow
located here in the west and actually
about several miles to the west of that
is the Everglades and so moving east we
have Memorial Hospital West here
Pembroke and then our flagship hospital
in the more regional hospital that has
on the same campus our children's
hospital that you would imagine your
children's hospital and then lastly down
here's our lemoore original hospital
south and that's where our molecular lab
is located and then actually if you go
several miles east that's uh you're at
the beach so just kind of give you an
overview of our in kind of physical
environment and where our molecular lab
centralized obviously specimens need to
get delivered in a timely manner and so
it's always
challenge in southbourne traffic for
couriers to get specimens over here from
our Miramar hospital west and then
headed to our molecular laboratory so
yeah it is quite a challenge and as the
crow flies i guess you can prompt this
from Middlemore Hospital over to
regional South it's about 12 14 miles
but obviously the traffic and will be
will feel like much longer so so getting
into sort of the need of the talk when
implementing any kind of infection
control program it's it's good to
understand the scope of the problem
you're trying to address and and so
obviously for us today we're going to
discussing MRSA prevalence and I wanted
to sort of start out in sort of a united
states national level kind of drill down
to Florida level and then talk about our
specific environment here so um Jarvis
at all and I have reference articles
down here at the bottom they the
author's performed kind of a snapshot
study back in two thousand six and then
in 2010 and looking at not only
infection rate but interestingly they
also looked at colonization rate and
these were questionnaires that were
submitted to hospitals within the a pic
membership of the Association for
professionals and infection control and
so they they took snapshots at these two
different times and and I have to
apologize that the the data here for
this 2006 2000 should be reverso in 2006
it should be 46.3 colonization rate in
2010 and actually showed an increase in
colonization rate at sixty six point
four so keeping that in mind there was
an increase in colonization rate and one
could argue that the it's because the
there's an increase in a number of
institutions performing Mercer screening
compared to the prior year so that's
kind of interesting to show that yes
we're detecting more colonization but is
that because now more in
actions are screening for an M are safe
and then if you look at infection rate
in here you can see where it's actually
the climb in the Merse infection rate
again one can infer that healthcare
workers health care institutions are
just more aware of MRSA and again
implementing not only screening programs
but then potentially implementing
decolonization regimens for those that
are commercially colonized and then this
last column when you look at the percent
detected with it or at least less than
48 hours of hospital admission sort of
gives an indication that most patients
are already presenting to the hospital
colonize rumors and this sort of
coincides with the incidence of or
increasing incidence of
community-acquired mrs day and another
set of data to look at and this is from
the cdc and this is actually from 2013
data that was published just earlier
this year in January CDC put out a
national state health care-associated
infections progress report and so it's
another way of looking at the scope of
Mercia and so this slide can be is kind
of busy so I'll try and go through it
and kind of give the explanations you
see here they worse excuse me CDC
correlated this data basically us number
of use hospitals throughout the u.s.
submitted data based on infection rates
and looking at the catheter excuse me a
central line associated bloodstream
infections catheter-associated UTIs
surgical site infections and then of
course the thing to focus here is mrsa
bacteremia and you can see with the
number of hospitals reporting and they
report the data as an as an SI are as
you see here in this last column and si
R stands for standardized infection
ratio so it's a way to normalize the
data so that you can truly compare from
one one year to another one state to
another to get an idea of where you
stand and the lower the SI are the
better you are so generally speaking as
an
as a nation when you look at the 2013 SI
r 0.92 and you can see there's a
national baseline that was established
in 2011 so we're actually lower this
year which is which is indicative of it
overall efforts towards being aware of
hospital-acquired infections and Mercer
back green is in general and then
compared to the prior year 2012 to 2013
again a five percent decrease in the SI
are however when you drill down to the
state of Florida obviously there's going
to be kind of more specific numbers and
when you look at and focus on bacteremia
you can see here Florida's not doing the
best job but again it's sort of
indicated by the number of hospitals
that submit data so there's a caveat to
the data being presented here but you
know it gives us an indicator of
generally speaking how well your
particular state is doing and this
report has all the 50 states in this
document so it's kind of a good idea to
see how you compare with others and MC
where and how the state is doing with
regards to hospital acquired infections
and then another way to look at it is to
look at the impact on the sort of
estimated annual death rate and this is
the CDC data looking at the antibiotic
resistant threats in 2013 as you can see
going down the list of the carbon panel
resistant enterobacteriaceae North I
dirt-resistant s you go back door from
connoisseur is this in Canada the SPLC
Arnie's multidrug-resistant pseudomonas
as well as drug-resistant MTV seed if
they hover around five six percent
annual death rate and then when you look
at methicillin-resistant Staph aureus
see here the estimating out death rate
approaching fourteen percent so again
Marissa being Mason a larger percentage
of contributing to the estimated annual
death rate so again another indication
trying to understand the scope of
of Mercia and then sort of drilling down
to our institution this is anti by
granting distances mersa that's been
isolated as a result in a clinical or
clinical infection that not not for
screening so just to give you an idea
the majority of Staph aureus that we
isolate in our microbiology laboratory
is mrs a so again just giving an
indication of kind of a scope of the
problem and i have a ladder slide that
actually shows a point prevalence study
we did and i'll discuss that more into
the planning stages and development
stages that we did but again it's sort
of interesting data just to understand
kind of the national scope and then as
you drill down to your specific
environment now one of the things that
sort of worked its way into kind of
institutional medical practices is
legislation and and these art and
generally speaking these aren't
necessarily a medically based but again
something that in reality we have to
deal with and so this is a number of
states have actually implemented
legislation and enacted laws saying that
health care institutions need to develop
or establish a mercer screening program
and you can see here this is data from
actually less last updated to see down
at the bottom of 2011 so these are the
states and blue are the ones that have
enacted and implemented mersa ross vs
weaning Rost so that they're required to
undergo or implementing more screening
program the state of florida at least
since back in 2011 and through today
they've at least discussed making it a
legislation but i don't think anything
has come to fruition yet but our
healthcare institution does voluntarily
report the our surgical site infections
and other hospital acquired infections
and so it's part of a initiative from
the state to sort of track these
in doggy business so again legislation
working its way a pic and Shay a pic the
Association professional flesh control
and Shay which is the Society for
healthcare epidemiology of America put
out a statement in 2007 basically
stating and I have here a quote from the
document position statement saying that
they do not support legislation to
mandate use of active surveillance
former so the area or any other
antimicrobial resistant pathogens so so
again it's up to the institution and its
each institution is going to be
different have a different environment
so it's hard to put sort of a blanket
legislation or in practice to really
apply to all institutions because some
institutions may not have an immersive
problem or other infectious disease
related problem and some institutions
might it just really depends and that's
something that if you're seriously
considering implementing some sort of
infection control program that it's
important again to understand the scope
of the problem with in your settings so
why screen for mr sales soar that's the
kind of the big question of you know why
things as you go forward with this and
there's a number of literature articles
editorials suggesting the benefits of
mrsa screening and and then there's on
the sort of the opposite end there's
there's articles and editorials
suggesting a lack of benefit for
immersive screening and one of the
problems and when you read these
literature articles and editorials is
that each again each institution is
going to be different the patient
population with an inch institution is
going to be different and then also the
method of how your screening whether it
be a culture versus molecular and i
think with any infection control program
there's not really any true case control
studies to really show okay specifically
a particular vegetable measure is the
sole cause or reason like
successful seen on the other end so um
infection troll it's typically a bundle
approach you have various facets trying
to work together towards a common goal
or program so again it's hard to really
have a true case-control study and I
just put one reference here and from the
journal of clinical microbiology is the
screen or not the screen for mrs a and
it's a particularly good article with a
sort of a point-counterpoint one of the
authors is from an institution obviously
that has mrsa screening program in place
and has implemented and shown success
and then others the other institutions
again they have not implemented mercer
screening and they give they give very
compelling reasons on both ends so to
get into our specific environment in our
planning and implementation and i show
here kind of a timeline and we really
started planning and developing this
back in november two thousand seven i
had attended a conference or one of our
tech control practitioners had attended
a different conference and we came back
and we shared notes and actually mean
that's kind of where this whole
inception of mercy screening in our
institution was sort of born how we
thought it was a worthwhile effort and
so we started that initiative and
getting firstly administrative support
and in kind of infectious disease
infection control support to say okay
yeah this is going to be beneficial we
think this is going to be beneficial
versus no it's not so with something
like this it really requires a top-down
effort from the administration and then
it's sort of a trickles down to the
clinical staff nursing staff I mean oh
ho I mean from A to Z it really affects
the whole institution and so I I
highlight here some of the bullet points
that were important in sort of getting
getting the Planning and Development
going and really when you look at
reforming the most
disciplinary teams it's really important
to involve all the stakeholders and this
is something that we probably took a lot
of time Bobby the bulk of the planning
and development and just coordinating
the efforts between the different
disciplines obviously laboratory
infection control but medical staff
nursing staff administration and course
one of the difficulties we came across
was just with the infectious disease
conditions for the system for our health
care system they they they obviously saw
the benefit they were on board with us
meadow I'm they're busy clinicians
they're still seeing patients they're
doing consults and so they were there
they were with us in spirit but it was
hard to really get the F relevant to
really spread the word to at least
clinician the clinician interaction so
it really eventually became a laboratory
in flesh control kind of spearheaded
effort towards getting this program off
the ground and I mentioned obviously
administration here being important
pharmacy was important because we ate
our in our educational efforts were that
if a mersa patient or a patient murmurs
i colonized and they would undergo
decolonization regimen and and so so
that was key to get them on board
obviously for the back to ban and core
exiting decolonization one of the
educational at least a couple of
educational efforts we did was bring in
speakers from institutions that I've
already implemented Mercer screening so
it's always good for our clinicians are
administrative staff to hear from other
outside institutions that they've went
through this process that they've
actually had success with the process
and so it was good to hear outside of us
the laboratory infect control telling
administration medical staff to hear
this outside person non non healthcare
system person tell their story tell
their successes tell their challenges so
that we can best
adapt a mercial screening program to fit
our institution and then it goes without
saying with the patient bed control
obviously the reflection possible it's a
semi-private room a facility and so the
placement of patients is needs to be
orchestrated carefully just because
infection control did not run to cohort
a merciful colonized patient with a non
merci economize patients so there's a
that required a certain amount of effort
there thankfully our other institutions
are all private rooms or they really
didn't have that issue to deal with as
we do here at our flagship hospital i T
is key here just because in the
laboratory we're in the business of
information delivery so it's important
to get results at and timely manner and
so that infection control medical staff
nurses have is aware and can take the
appropriate measures then that would be
contact precautions and then inserting
the decolonization regimen initially in
the planning development or infection
control and medical staff one at the
laboratory to call on all our positives
to the floor is essentially treating it
as a critical value which we felt our
staff is not would not be the best use
of their time I mean we need our medical
technologist to be medical technologist
and and at the time the healthcare
system had a few months before that had
implemented thera doc and if you're not
from North arrow doc it's a relational
database that marries microbiology
laboratory data with pharmacy and with
infection control so and the neat thing
about the Pharaoh doc is that the end
users infection control nursing
clinicians can customize alerts so that
infection Carlton set up okay when a
merciless screening results come back
positive I want to be alerted and that's
either by email or can done by page so
at least they're automatically alerted
and that sort of eliminate
the requirement right by the
technologies and really it's done in a
more timely manner than it could be done
by person trying to find someone so so
that's good and so now what we have is
is important to have that Farrah doc
implementation in place so we definitely
took advantage of that so next as they
say a picture is worth a thousand words
and so what we love we presented to our
administration is that okay because we
don't have a Mercer program place this
is what we're capturing as far as
patients with a clinical Mercer
infection now knowing what mersa
conization the implications with that we
felt we presented the administration of
hey we're only getting the tip of the
iceberg what about all those patients
that are just mercial colonized and not
overtly have a clinical infection so
this was kind of the idea of identifying
these patients so that they can so that
appropriate precautions can be
implemented decolonization and they
don't service whether reservoirs of
infection within our healthcare
institution and there was a study in
clinical infectious diseases in 2004
that stated that about thirty percent of
those that are colonized with Marissa
that are hospitalized actually end up
with an infection with their own
colonizing versus strain so again the
implications is preventing and
identifying reservoirs of Mercer
colonization and then was preventing a
most infection in these patients that
immersive colonized so to get into kind
of our strategy for Mercer screening
what we have oh there's ten of two
schools of thought you can go Universal
route and screen everyone that that
comes in two men get submitted to your
healthcare institution you can also
selectively target high-risk patient
screening and
we didn't know which way to go
logistically and probably for the sake
of me the laboratory staff we kind of
wanted to avoid the universal screening
just because we'd be testing everyone
but we really needed to know which way
to go and so that's where point
prevalence studies came in and so what
we did was a one-day snapshot within our
healthcare institution we looked and
took an anterior near swab of all of our
impatience as long as they consented and
we had almost ninety nine percent
consent that so we got a good
representation of the impatience and our
healthcare system when we found that
nine percent of our impatience arm
Ursula colonized and when we drill down
and looked at those mersa colonized
patients we found that all those fit in
our high-risk category and so just to
define what our high-risk category is we
we we took a mix of what we've seen at
other healthcare institutions that have
already implemented a murse screening
program and then we took some of the
what a pic considers high-risk patients
so we came up with this list and that so
as you see critical care admissions of
transfers or whether they're admitted
directly the ICU or they may be on the
general floor and if they haven't been
screened yet they're going to be
screened before they as a yet or as they
entered the ICU wards admissions for
long-term care facilities patients who
have previously tested mersa positive
and that's colonization or had a
documented mersa infection dialysis
patients and chronic media renal failure
patients admissions with skin and soft
tissue infections and then just those
frequent flyers that seem to be up
showing up with increased frequency to
urban our healthcare institutions
additionally we also implemented mercer
screening as part of a pre-surgical
workup of when patients come in usually
five to seven days before their
procedure is scheduled
along with the normal routine blood work
lab work they will get an anterior near
swab and get tested for Mercer
colonization and again if positive its
communicated back to them and the script
skin to them to go to the pharmacy to
get a the decolonization regimen of the
Clorox Indian bacteria and so by the
time they show up to or for that
procedure they should be colonized and
at least protected for that time during
the procedure so getting into at least
the when you talk about what molecular
screening or mercy screening we did
evaluate molecular versus a chrome auger
which is a its culture media but it if
it's mrs a and then it shows up a
particular color so it's somewhat
eliminates some of the post testing that
you need you to confirm although as I'm
sure many of you know is the chrome
muggers aren't completely one hundred
percent specific and there are some
issues and false positives so I think
one of the big limitations for us of why
we did not go with culture is just
because of the time issue of getting
result out in 18 to 24 hours at least 24
culture while with a screening test
right now we're getting results out from
about 11 12 hours actually scuze me 12
to 14 hours so so I'll talk more about
our turnaround time later on and I
mentioned the decolonization regimen and
here is the specific one that we use we
actually got from another healthcare
institution so it's with a back term an
ointment in the mayor's two times daily
and then chlorhexidine bad for wipe down
depending on how inventory innovation
being so the total decolonization
regimen is about seven days and then
just revisiting the timeline so again
that timeline for the Planning
development beginning in november two
thousand seven and then we actually went
live october two thousand eight one of
the difficulties with going live in
october in parallel we were molecular
lab is actually moving to
a different laboratory just for sake of
space it was bigger space and so we
actually ended up moving September 2008
and into our laboratory new laboratory
at the time and so we had about a month
to really get everything set up
validated and ready to go and thankfully
with IT in our lab staff we were able to
go live and is actually mid october two
thousand eight we decided to go hospital
by hospital versus a big bang approach
as i mentioned earlier in the
introduction slides you saw our big our
healthcare institution is and we felt
doing life with a smaller hospital we
can work out the kinks and operational
things that and it's impossible to
anticipate all those things in the pre a
pre go live stage and so it was good
that we start small get her feet wet so
to speak work out the kinks and then and
then expand and you can see the timeline
of when we went live with various
hospitals and ultimately going live may
2009 took about a good six months seven
months to go live with the entire
healthcare system on board so just very
lastly to get into some of the mercial
screening outcomes and metrics again we
can it's good for our administration
anything good for us to show that we're
having a positive benefit on the patient
side of things and and so so so here's
some of the data and I i have here 16 17
hour turnaround time and that was
actually early this year before we had
three shifts and now with the three
shifts were able to get a result out
about 1214 hours and so that's from time
to collection to time to result and we
usually have two runs per day so we
haven't run starting around midday and
then and then usually run on our third
shift so again we're able to at least
get a turnaround time that satisfactory
for our infection control practitioners
again with their adult day
automatically get alerted so it really
takes at that time if we were to call
all those positive results and then I
mentioned the presurgical screening is
usually about five to seven days prior
to schedule procedures so we definitely
get those results out a timely manner so
that the clinician can implement the the
appropriate economization protocol and
then here's looking at our at least
experience from the laboratory so in the
orange bars represent our versus
screaming volumes that we've seen
throughout the years through the end of
2014 and then the blue bars represent
the positivity rate so you can see here
with the volumes increasing throughout
the years here and we've noticed I mean
in general increase patient population
showing up at our healthcare
institutions so as time has gone on
we've had more patients coming in and
that's really led to our increase in
volumes again the positivity rate you
can see here and excuse me the next
slide I actually had positivity rate so
this is sort of capturing the latter
half of in 2008 and 2009 so that's sort
of combined here in that first column
and you can see with our Mercer rate
sort of declining over time and it's
sort of it's remained steady around the
fourteen fifteen percent so this is what
we're seeing it's hard to say what this
means as far as our efforts in
identifying these were stationed and
common tod colonization but at least
it's sort of an interesting observation
to show a decline at Mercer colonization
of course one of the big things that our
finance people wanted to see was you
know what's what's this costing the
health care system and I should mention
ahead of time that the patient is not
charged for any of this testing so the
healthcare system felt this was a
patient safety initiative
that the health care system is where we
meet the cost for and we actually part
of our education to the patient is also
we prepared pamphlets for the patient on
patient families where it explains what
we're doing why we're doing it and and
so that they know that this is something
that the healthcare system is is
ultimately covering for at least for the
Mercer screening so in the yellow bars
is the lab testing and that obviously is
going to be the majority cost just
because of the testing the reagents and
so this is really only considering the
test the test reagents tech time is not
included obviously our texts are doing
other assays so it's harder it would
have been hard to at least break out
that time so this is really just looking
at reagents the blue bars represent the
pharmacy costs of the cost of the
decolonization regimen and then the
green line here I have as the total cost
a lab plus pharmacy and you can see as
we expect with volumes increasing the
cost of the program has increased with
regards to lab and pharmacy I did not
include infection control the personal
protective equipment required for
contact precautions just because these
patients sometimes there's another
reason why they they are under contact
precautions and it may not necessarily
be for MRSA in the beginning so it's
hard to account for that and also
there's multiple times that healthcare
workers go into a patient's room and
they put on and take off these personal
protective equipment so I did not
include that just to make it relatively
easy to come up with a kind of a
estimated kind of laboratory pharmacy
costs and so the next slide here showing
in the blue line showing the decline in
the number of mercy hospital acquired
infections november two thousand eight
we weren't completely live really live
only the writer the latter quarter of
the year so
we get a documented 184 Mercer hospital
are infections see over time going to
2014 we had 29 hospital or infections
and so again showing a decline in murcia
hospital-acquired infections but then
also we wanted to put a dollar figure
and they saw our infection control
worked with our finance people to come
up with okay what's it cost of health
care system to to care for a mrsa h AI
or hospital acquired infection so they
came up with about ten thousand dollars
per infection and if you look in the
literature we think this is a loan this
9000 number is loaded with a low number
we've seen or I've seen numbers as high
as 27,000 35,000 as the excess cost of a
health care solution provides for caring
for Mercer patient that has had mercy
hae so but regardless here's the numbers
that were calculated so basically 184
mersa h AI is x 9404 9u camp that's how
i came up with these numbers here you
can see over time again less and less
expense for mrsa a che eyes and so this
was something that a aardman upper
administration and our finance people
saw benefit now one of the things in
trying to concepts for our finance
people to get used to us that cost
avoidance so what are we avoiding
spending and it's hard for it was hard
for them to sort of grasp this concept
just because it's not a specific fine
item in a budget it's something that we
didn't spend so one of the big
assumptions here if you look for 2008
here again the this blue blue bars
represent oh the cost that the
healthcare system is spending to care
for marissa HDI and the assumption here
is that if we did not have a Mercer
screening program in 2009 through 2014
that I made these
okay we would have 184 versa a che is
across the board so again that's a big
assumption but if we didn't have a
merciless screening program again
looking at the cost of avoidance in the
orange bars so again this is what to be
avoided potentially avoid in spending
for amercia h AI and so again going from
415,000 in 2009 all the right two of
these estimated for 2014 and cost
avoidance of 1.4 million dollars so
again get gave administration and
finance little idea of what we avoided
spending again talking with your finance
people is good to keep that
communication open because obviously
they they speak a different language
than lab and and it's always good to
like an equal them and show that we're
trying to kind of kind of explain the
concepts and not only you know it's a
two-way street so it was it was it was
good at least have those discussions
with them but again they're starting to
get the idea of cost of rings because
we've used that term and other
laboratory testing be brought in so
again good to establish that
relationship with your findings folks so
i apologize i doing dealing with some
technical difficulties um so in this in
this slide here where i put together the
cost of the what we were spending you
know down here 2008-2009 as far as the
blue bars again the orange bars up here
up top represent the cost avoidance that
we estimated and in gray here is where i
put the cost of the MERS of the program
of the pharmacy and laboratories you can
see perhaps in the beginning we are
spending 1.3 million 1.3 million plus
the 343,000 again
exceeding the cost of Rodin's but as
time goes on you can see here with
518,000 plus two 204,000 again made
probably closer to eight hundred
thousand again cost of writing here 1.4
million dollars so it gives us an idea
of where we stand is from a financial
perspective again not a true cost
analysis but at least give us an idea of
kind of the benefit we saw on the client
of mrsa a che is and then the fine from
a financial perspective as well so I in
to summarize all those kind of charts I
showed we saw an eighty-four percent
decline in murcia h AI is from 2008 to
2014 again adding up those orange bars
in the cost avoidance assumptions of 6.5
million dollars that cost avoided and so
again an estimation there but gives
gives administration something tangible
to kind of hold on to and and identify
with and and something that we feel that
our administration is proud of to
implement a patient safety initiative
being a public health care institution
everything to do is sort of them erotic
feel like we're in a fishbowl and
everyone can see what we do so it's good
to show some benefits to bringing in and
spending the money on testing and
expenses for an immersive screening
program the show the benefits on the
other end so I just want to close out
that you know with merciless screening
and really any inflection troll
initiative it's a multi-disciplinary
effort not only considering the
pre-analytical steps and from collecting
the sample identifying the patient
performing the tests getting the
positive result alert out but then it
starts a trigger or a sort of a
downstream effect of getting the
clinicians identified or notified that
the you know the patient's Mercer
colonized if I control gates of oral
pharmacy know
seeing an ultimately patient discharge
environmental services you can see where
there's a downstream effect and it's a
really a multidisciplinary effort to get
to get a mercial screening program off
off the ground here they in you know
I've heard the statistic where
laboratory testing in general is about
three percent of the healthcare dollar
yet clinicians and other medical
decisions seventy percent of those
decisions are based off of webos or data
so the laboratory is certainly a key
part but we need all the pieces working
together in order to show any kind of
success so thank you for joining me and
and I will now take any questions thank
you okay so we have some questions
coming in in the queue a box I'm just
kind of read these up says here after
this one of the first question after the
seven day regimen of treatment for mr
say do you keep your patients in
isolation so yeah yes we do just because
they've been identified and typically
our patients are average like this thing
is maybe four or five days so typically
they're released and once they're
discharged they're they're told to
maintain and complete the regimen of
course once they're outside the system
it's hard to police that but at least we
do try and keep in my summation usually
if they're going to be in longer than
seven days there's usually something
some other underlying disease or reason
why they're still in house so again you
just sort of keep that isolation going
the second question when I see that's
coming across what Marcel molecular test
methods have you used or are using so we
did start out with a lab develop test
back in two thousand eight so it was a
it was a test that identified staph
aureus from the other coagulase-negative
staff so is a molecular method
and then any staph aureus that was
identified we actually ran those samples
or they were reflex to the gene Xpert
mersa SI so this is 2008 and we actually
were running that for a while and then
and the ASR or lab developed SPG was
developed on the Roche lightcycler we
then migrated over to the roche mersa
advanced as they got their mercy SI fda
approved so we were running that for a
while again with the volumes I there was
a front end step that in processes that
that required a lot of manual steps
where I would say a lot of mimesis but
it was manually done by the text where
they had to break off the swab into a
sort of a lysis buffer tube and then
preparation of pcr mastermix and so with
our volumes it got to be a little bit
burdensome for our text and so we
actually been did my grade ores in the
meeting max and which is what we're
currently using and the good thing is
that medium axis is semi automated so
you load the reagents you load the
patient samples if there you do have to
break off this rom into a MRSA tune that
goes on to the instrument once you load
the instrument with your agents and
samples it does the extractions it does
as well as the pcr and then gives you
the amplification or it gives you the
final results so at least you have a
allows less hands-on time by our text so
they can do other more critical things
and there are a number of other mersa
assays out there that may benefit you
and I mentioned earlier we didn't
evaluate the kamagra again with a time
issue of writing that 18 24 hours we
felt that's turnaround time with a
molecular method would serve our
clinicians infecting infection control
better so next question do we need to
make it mandatory for every patient to
be screened for mercy colonization
before major surgeries well it's again
it's
it's up to the healthcare institution
it's to really determine if MRSA is a
huge problem in your institution and
you're seeing perhaps a high rate of
surgical site infections before your
surgery is I think that's something
you'll have to address internally to
really see okay if we implement
something and we prevent versus
infections could this be a means of
doing that by implementing a versus
reading program so you'll it's hard to
say without knowing the sort of
nitty-gritty details about your
particular institution so it's something
you'll have to look at and address next
question is do you check Staph aureus
methicillin sensitive collec- staff and
methicillin-resistant coin- staff so
right now no we do not that's something
that we've been looking at and actually
so again I don't think it currently at
least in the US there's no limit to my
knowledge fda approve essays that do
separate correct negative staff meth
system methadone sensitive there are
assets that will separate
methicillin-resistant Staph aureus from
methicillin sensitive staffers and so we
are initially kind of looking at that
product just because staff for is
whether it's mrs a or MSSA methicillin
sensitivity can be significant or not in
a patient as well so we're kind of
looking at that rub we haven't moved to
that essay yet so again something that
we're looking at a question comes with
the what's the current lab eration cost
for me d max MRSA I don't have those
specific cost numbers the cost numbers
that i showed incorporated those three
assays i mentioned that we migrated to
and from so i will have my email address
available afterwards so perhaps we can
talk more offline and
the general numbers with that let's see
this next question coming in did you
differentiate the hospital part mr say
from the patients who had mercer prior
to their hospital visit and i can't see
the rest of the question but uh and how
was I'll repeat the question so did you
differentiate the hospital park mrs de
from the patients who have mrs a prior
to the hospital visit and how was this
done so no we did not differentiate the
hospital acquired versa and i guess i
may be a little confused as to what in
reference does that mean what patients
that were coming in and then we identify
them are infection control tracks the
h.a ice or hospital prior infection so
hospital-acquired mr essays so they
follow that those numbers i'm sure they
have the Merse infections that came in
from the community that were not
considered an h AI so they have those
numbers so that was really an efficient
for a question that i can certainly find
out the answers for them if again I
think my contact information would be
available so that you can contact me
offline i can try to find the answers to
your question the next question is it
any experimental studies on the phage
therapy for mrs a and i have not seen
any and that's an interesting concept i
again not having specifically looked in
detail to any kind of therapeutic use of
bacteriophages for mr say but certainly
certainly an interesting question I'll
guys don't have a good answer for that
and then lastly or at least this last
question i have is can a vaccine be
developed to prevent mrs a if I guess
you can develop a vaccine to almost any
pathogen I guess the question is how do
you deal with the normal
flora because individuals can be
colonized with MRSA and not not coming
down with a clinical infection they just
are colonized and there's actually if
you there's an article that I don't have
the immediate references on in my head
but I knew they do talk about patients
can be intermittent colonizers they can
be persistent colonizers and then some
patients actually are seemingly
resistant to Mercer colonization so that
there's an interesting microcosm of
looking at the host factors and how
people can be those three categories of
persistent intermittent or sort of
resistant colonization I would it be
hard for a vaccine that target that just
because it can be normal flora and sort
of survives happily and it's sort of
along for the ride and with in-house
patients so again it's it's hard to say
for sure how effective a vaccine would
be but again I haven't looked at those
in detail about that next question I
have one would be on your Most Wanted
improvement list for current mursel
molecular test methods perhaps this
could be taken offline it seems to be a
more detailed question but I guess you
know one of the things with merciless
PCR testing in general is just trying to
take an account of all the more so types
there are as we know there's the MEK a
which is the genetic element responsible
for methicillin resistance and there's
different mech elements and one of the
you know advantages we saw with the BD
max is that it can detect next C which
currently in the US isn't that not a
very high prevalence but at least it's
been reported in Europe and now with the
world become smaller because of air
travel and being able to go from one
place to another within within a day
it's certainly bound to show up in us
sometime
so again I think vendors need to be
aware of all the different mech types
out there different elements for mrs a
genetic elements and just be aware that
because any genetic elements available
mutations observed can adversely affect
the performance of the assay is just
because primers and probes are go
developed to be specific for a certain
gene sequence of any of those jeans or
nucleotides are mutated again potential
needing to subpar performance or even
resulting in a false negative so again
something to be aware about I see that
there's no questions are further
questions so I guess I just want to
thank the audience and again by my
contact information should be made
available so that you know if any other
questions come up or some of the
questions that we better off to take
better able to talk to take off line and
I could help you I'll answer those
questions thank you everyone again for
joining us today and I turn it back to
Judy I would like to thank dr. Arcenas
for his presentation I would also like
to thank our sponsor roche diagnostics
for making it possible to bring this
presentation to you today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through februari third 2016 you'll
receive an email from us alerting you
when it's available on demand and posted
on Lavery com you are welcome to forward
this announcement to any colleagues who
aren't able to join in today thanks for
logging on and participating in today's
broadcast see you next time